es ist ein historischer moment 75 jahre
nach dem zweiten weltkrieg rauschen
eurofighter der luftwaffe
gemeinsam mit israelischen f 16
kampfjets am himmel über deutschland zum
ersten mal überhaupt kurz danach gehen
die flieger in den sinkflug setzen
schließlich am militärflugplatz nur
wenig auf von hier aus wollen sie
gemeinsam in den kommenden tagen üben
es schmerzt wir werden verschiedene
szenarien und aufgaben trainieren von
denen beide seiten profitieren über
unbekannteste hause fliegen in einer
anderen sprache und nach einer anderen
doktrin zu operieren bringt uns
unglaublich weiter im vergangenen jahr
hatten die deutschen an einer übung in
israel teilgenommen nun also der rück
besuch die israelis komme mit
kampffliegern tankern und learjets für
die israelische luftwaffe ist es das
einzige auslands manöver in diesem
corona ja in deutschland will man
gemeinsam den kampf von jet gegen jet
das ausschalten von modernen boden luft
raketenstellungen und den flug über
feindliches gebiet üben und die
besondere freundschaft zwischen der
deutschen und israelischen luftwaffe
weiter ausbauen
maximilian kiewel ist mir jetzt
zugeschaltet wir haben es gerade im
beitrag gehört es gibt dieses jahr nur
eine einzige übung im ausland und die
findet in deutschland statt warum gerade
hier ja für die israelis gibt es hier
etwas was sie so zu hause natürlich
nicht haben
dichte laubwälder grüne wiesen und den
deutschen eurofighter zum trainieren
das alles macht es für sie spannend und
interessant und dann ist da natürlich
auch diese besondere beziehung zwischen
den beiden luftwaffenchefs sie verbindet
eine tiefe freundschaft sie kennen sich
seit vielen jahren sind auch schon
zusammen geflogen
und so ist dann auch heute der deutsche
general gerhard mit seinem eurofighter
gestartet richtung deutsch
österreichische grenze geflogen und hat
dort in der luft die israelische
delegation willkommen geheißen ist mit
ihnen gemeinsam hier nach nrw geflogen
und hat sie nach nur wenig eskortiert
morgen soll außerdem ein historischer
flug stattfinden was kannst du uns
darüber sagen ja du hast es gesagt ein
historischer flug
früh am morgen starten die beiden
luftwaffenchefs gemeinsam in einem
learjet werden diskutiert von zwei
israelischen 11 16 und zwei deutschen
eurofightern dann passieren sie das
ehemalige konzentrationslager dachau
überfliegen dann das flugfeld in
fürstenfeldbruck wo 1972 während der
olympischen spiele elf israelische
olympioniken sportler von terroristen
ermordet worden
das alles soll an die erinnerung an die
an die vergangenheit erinnern und aber
vor allem auch die freundschaft zwischen
diesen beiden nationen weiter ausbauen